or Sky security and defense analyst
Michael Clarke joins me now and Michael
it's great to have you here some major
developments this morning what do you
think has happened here yeah it's big
story Vanessa um the Russian claimed
that it was a vehicle that exploded on
the bridge is ridiculous I mean if it
was an explosion it would have gone
upwards not come from underneath and you
can't get that much stuff into a vehicle
going over a bridge I mean bridges are
designed to withstand accidents of that
sort this is either a missile uh which
would be a missile heavier than the
ukrainians are supposed to have or a
special forces operation to sabotage the
bridge with explosives underneath in
which case they'll be making Hollywood
films about this for some time to come
because it was a huge Victory if it's a
special forces Victory to actually get
explosives under a bridge of that
magnitude in the middle of an area that
the Russians are guarding very very
severely and very carefully so whatever
it is it's a it's a big hit either a big
missile or a big Special Forces
operation and and although the
ukrainians will not claim it yet
um it's a huge victory for them similar
to the sinking of the mosfer the uh the
flagship in the Black Sea it's a big
blow to the Russians in that respect
absolutely I guess the key question here
is why has this particular bridge then
been targeted and also as you were data
I mean you've alluded to some of that
what is the significance then for
Ukraine yeah the significance is is the
importance of the bridge I mean until
this bridge was built was in it was
opened in 2018 by Mr Putin to Great
Fanfare
um it was the only link between Russia
proper and Crimea that didn't go through
uh Ukraine and so the only way that the
Russians could keep Crimea directly
supplied was via that bridge before the
bridge it was just a ferry the Kirsch
Ferry which used to run like every two
hours and just take a few Vehicles it
was very very small link so that bridge
was vital and of course it's been vital
in water supply because it was the line
through which the Russians easily got
their equipment into Crimea and out to
the cursing region now with the bridge
down and it won't be down forever but
the bridge down the Russians have now
got to rely on stuff from Billy ants and
Mario poll so they've got to take things
by effectively by sea to marry Paul and
berliance and then use the one decent
rail line which is coming within range
now of of uh Ukrainian uh artillery so
Russian supply lines intercoursin will
be affected by this in quite a big way
however this is temporary the Russians
Will Will Repair the bridge for sure and
if the ukrainians could hit the rail
Bridge more uh strongly than they
obviously did then that would be better
for them but to bring the road bridge
down is a tremendous achievement and to
damage the rail bridge is still pretty
good my guess is that this will give the
ukrainians maybe two weeks three weeks
until this is all repaired of Advantage
where the Russians will find it really
difficult to get any more equipment into
the cursing region where they're already
in trouble absolutely and I think most
people then will be wondering what
impact will this then have on Putin and
the warm moving forward it's a big one
because Mr Putin opened this bridge in
2018 to Great Fanfare and of course for
him this was the symbol of the fact that
Crimea was now Russian Crimea had been
conquered in 2014 they've been annexed
by Russia illegally and the idea of
linking Russia directly to Crimea via
the bridge was a way of saying this of
course is now Russian no question about
it so he put his prestige on the line by
saying that he never thought he would
have to go back on it and you know given
the fact that the Memorial Institute
sakharov's Institute was was awarded the
Peace Prize yesterday the Nobel Peace
Prize and this overnight it hasn't been
a great birthday 70th birthday
celebration for him one way or another
not at all major setback for him isn't
it indeed Michael thank you